[Musica]
innanzitutto buongiorno e comincerei
così un giorno ero in quinta liceo e
stavo seguendo una lezione di matematica
la professoressa di matematica stava
cercando di spiegare anzi per la
precisione lei stava spiegando ero io
che stavo cercando di capire le funzioni
esponenziali che sono assolutamente a me
ignote per me era veramente difficile
capire il senso della matematica
e infatti non lo capivo mi venne
spontaneo per alleviare le mie pene di
questa tortura che era la matematica per
me in quinta liceo fare una domanda che
da quel momento in avanti io feci a
tutte le persone che incontrai e che mi
stavano insegnando qualcosa e la domanda
era semplicemente questa ma la
matematica che cos'è
a che cosa serve la matematica
professoressa mi disse
bella domanda la ringrazio di se vedete
da quando il mondo il mondo gli esseri
umani hanno l'esigenza di rappresentare
nella realtà hanno bisogno di
rappresentare la realtà perché
attraverso la rappresentazione della
realtà cercano fra le altre cose di dare
alcune risposte alle grandi domande
degli esseri umani da dove veniamo per
che nasciamo cosa siamo qui a fare
perché esiste il dolore perché esiste la
morte
molto semplicemente ad un certo punto
alcuni esseri umani si sono posti il
problema è l'obiettivo di descrivere la
realtà attraverso i numeri la matematica
è la descrizione della realtà attraverso
i numeri
e in effetti tutto quello che ci
circonda può essere espresso attraverso
una funzione questo microfono se
lawrence e lo disegniamo su un computer
quello che ne risulta è una funzione
matematica la matematica
la rappresentazione della realtà
attraverso i numeri melo poteva anche
dire qualche anno prima mi evitavo
alcune torture inutili senza sapere che
cosa stessi facendo la matematica la
rappresentazione della realtà attraverso
i numeri colui il quale rappresenta la
realtà con i pennelli e colori si chiama
pittore colui il quale rappresenta la
realtà con uno scalpello e materiali in
legno il marmo o quello che sceglie è lo
scultore chi sceglie di rappresentare la
realtà attraverso le parole è il poeta o
lo scrittore coloro i quali cercano ed
esprimono la realtà attraverso i suoni
si chiamano musicisti la musica è la
rappresentazione della realtà attraverso
i suoni si ha della realtà fenomenica
sia della realtà emotiva questo è la
musica la musica è una lingua è una
lingua che ha una sua sintassi è una
lingua che ha una sua grammatica è una
lingua cana su una sua punteggiatura un
suo vocabolario i grandissimi
compositori del passato che possedevano
in maniera solidissima questa lingua
scelsero e decisero di non associare
altre forme espressive come per esempio
la parola alla musica ma il significato
arrivava lo stesso quando bethoven
scrive la quinta anton ohno
toro di terrore di dover richiedere
questo tondo andando è il destino che
bussa questo senso di inquietudine di
sospensione e ha colpito in in egual
misura tutti gli esseri umani che ne
sono entrati in contatto da quando
questa composizione è stata composta
fino adesso e lo sarà anche in futuro il
senso di inquietudine non sono quelle
note non è l'aspetto tecnico oppure non
solo è il senso di inquietudine alcuni
compositori o per scelta o per o perché
non possedevano i giusti strumenti
questa lingua che è la musica maniera
così solida decisero di associare alla
musica e altre forme espressive come la
parola parola musica le metto insieme
canzone le grandi canzoni sono le
canzoni dove le parole e la musica
dicono la stessa cosa se ha una grande
canzone tu toglie le parole lasci solo
la musica la musica dice la stessa cosa
delle parole
questa è una grande canzone questo
insegnamento me lo ritrovai anni dopo
parecchi anni dopo quando decisi in
maniera un po improvvida di dirigere
l'orchestra di sanremo per chi non è
italiano il festival di sanremo è il più
importante festival di musica pop barra
popolare che c'è in italia
decisi di
a dirigere l'orchestra ma la direzione
d'orchestra è una materia se stante nei
conservatori c è la materia di direzione
d'orchestra
ora io studio e ho studiato musica da
quando avevo dieci anni ma non avevo
studiato direzione d'orchestra
infatti alla prima prova con l'orchestra
di sanremo feci una pessima figura
feci una pessima figura un po perché non
riuscivo a comunicare bene con gli
orchestrali un po non avevo la
sensazione di avere le briglie
dell'orchestra in mano
l'orchestra quando un direttore
d'orchestra ce l'ha in mano va dove
decide il direttore d'orchestra io non
ho deciso niente quel giorno erano
completamente cavalli imbizzarriti e io
non riuscivo a domarli bene fra la prima
prova dell'orchestra di sanremo e la
seconda prova c'erano tre settimane in
queste tre settimane io decisi di
studiare a fondo
studiai con l'aiuto di un direttore
d'orchestra mio amico che si chiama
marcello faneschi e ringrazierò per
tutta la vita
tra l'altro abita da queste parti e poi
mi tuffai in youtube per cercare i
tutorial di direzione d'orchestra su
youtube ci sono i tutorial di tutto ci
saranno state anche quelli di direzione
d'orchestra infatti c'erano anche quelli
di direzione d'orchestra mai tutorial di
su youtube di direzione d'orchestra non
mi davano la chiave che stavo cercando
per cercare di riprendere in mano ste
benedette briglie perché mi davano delle
indicazioni tecniche come si di il gesto
l'eleganza del gesto come si dirige in
quattro quarti come si dirige un
trequarti un se ottave non era quello
che stavo andando a cercare io stavo
cercando come sir come si comunica ai
musicisti l'espressività di quello che
sta che volevo ottenere in maniera del
tutto casuale
incontrai in questo percorso un video
che cambiò totalmente il mio modo di
vedere e la musica e la direzione
d'orchestra
era un video dove leonard bernstein uno
dei più grandi direttori artisti e
direttori d'orchestra della storia
dell'umanità
spiegava un'orchestra giovanile per poi
dirigerla la sagra della primavera di
stravinskij è un video che dura due ore
ora io l'ho ridotto a 2 minuti e leonard
est per spiegare all'orchestra giovanile
la sagra della primavera non indica non
gli dà indicazioni tecniche non gli dice
questo è un do questo è un re questioni
gli dà delle indicazioni cerca sempre di
creare un filo con la realtà per cercare
di dare delle immagini ai musicisti in
maniera tale che la nota non sia solo la
nota ma sia un racconto sia qualcosa che
abbia per l'appunto il famosissimo
collegamento con la realtà quel video
cambiò per sempre il mio modo di vedere
la direzione d'orchestra e la musica
possiamo vederne un estratto now il
writer spring
orba sexy
ed ora sente sempre da collegamento
[Musica]
spiegando cosa tecnica maniera tale da
ottenere una sorta di barrito di ruggito
non riesce a ottenere spiegato
[Musica]
una volta dopo risanare lo zaino storica
ma ancora una volta di leonard bernstein
il più uno dei più grandi di tutti i
tempi
mi cambiò completamente la prospettiva
questo era quello che stavo cercando per
dirigere l'orchestra tre settimane dopo
seconda prova con l'orchestra di sanremo
l'ultima parte del brano che dovevo che
dovevo dirigere era una sorta di valzer
mi faceva taratata tir era datata rara
da tarana rara
lo spartito era scritto in maniera
corretta la grammatica musicale era
corretta c'era tutto c'era indicata la
dinamica al passaggio dal pianissimo al
fortissimo tutto c'era scritto tutto
sullo spartito era uno spartito scritto
drammaticamente in maniera corretta ma
non riuscivo a ottenere quello che
voleva ottenere non c'era la gioia
giusta in quello che stavano eseguendo e
allora ricordandomi di questo video
gli dissi signori questo è il finale di
una storia d'amore finalmente queste due
persone
dopo un momento di difficoltà riescono
ad amarsi e possono amarsi
tranquillamente sono due giovani che
vanno in un prato con i retini a caccia
di farfalle è la scena di gioia più
clamorosa che voi potete immaginarvi
pronti
un due tre.un 23 tarara it a tirar e
violini facendo le stesse note ballavano
e violoncelli ballavano e facevano
ballare
era quello che volevamo ottenere quello
che voleva ottenere in quel momento ho
sentito le briglie in mano una delle
sensazioni più belle della mia vita non
ho mai più diretto in vita mia dopo
quello sempre per facendo riferimento
alla figura pessima che ho fatto alla
prima lezione alla prima prova bene
concludo il mio intervento facendo vi
sentire ora un brano di un comprano jazz
di un compositore
palermitano che si chiama salvatore
bonafede in questo brano che si intitola
matrimoni non ci sono parole ma ci sono
parole
tre strumenti principali il pianoforte
la tromba e il sassofono contralto
matrimoni dove a un certo punto c'è un
tema iniziale che prelude alla festa e
poi la tromba e il sassofono si parlano
e non si dicono belle cose la tromba
donna il sassofono uomo partiamo grazie
[Musica]
forte e adesso sfumato fa il suo
discorso è di certo punto di vista sulla
cosa
e da questo momento in avanti ma la
tromba con adesso
ecco fernando
il tavolo non sappiamo quindi che non si
sopportano dunque è per te e tua madre
no guarda torino le madri che si doveva
ma maniera tua madre
forza di anatre aveva pure che la lista
troppo
forse sì
dico
no no no
mentre mondo
beh
[Musica]
io
le gesta bagnato
sto pagando
[Musica]
buoni
io faccio l'amore
voi
[Musica]
no
grazie
[Applauso]